[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so talk about a rough week terrorist
attack at kabul airport killing 13 u.s
service members 10 marines two army
soldiers and one navy corpsman at least
160 afghans were killed that mayhem
believed to be uh carried out by the
islamic group isis k
the president tried to speak then
gensake spoke
but somehow i don't feel comfortable
comforted the president seemed defeated
lost between spasms of anger then
followed instructions to use a list of
reporters given to him by whoever is
really in charge and jen was just jen
acting as though she was doing us a
favor instead of her job a job i
wouldn't wish on my worst enemy and
besides perino already was press
secretary
i go back to one question though how
could everyone but the people in charge
not see this coming
maybe they were so busy distracting us
that they got distracted while
distracting us
look i'm an english major magazine
editor turned class clown with an
obsession over unicorns and i could see
this coming
hell the blind shake could see this
coming after a conference call with
helen keller how could the people in
charge not
perhaps they did and just assumed
carnage was the price we pay or maybe
they just underestimated the risk which
boggles the mind but again i'm no expert
and yet how do i know better
going forward how can we have any
confidence in our leaders i wouldn't let
them leave my paintball team
they make the bay of pigs look well
thought out
i mean who gives control of the airport
perimeter to the taliban as well as info
on americans can we have made it any
easier for these medieval maggots oh
they will say hey we had no choice but
when has the military with the best
weapons not had a choice instead they
led us to a place where there was no
plan b
that's not leadership that's resignation
and where are the resignations where are
the firings maybe general milley should
put down the robin d'angelo and pick up
the art of war
the upside no more arguments over the
meaning of the word stranded
we got a good visual of that at the
podium yesterday
biden is stranded
when really it's on the democrats and
the media they only wanted joe to win
but not to govern
and now he has to lead and he can't
don't even think of impeachment who
could replace him it's incredible how
the woke embrace has destroyed the
democratic party you can't lead a
country you think is racist while
obsessing over pronouns and crackpots
and viking hats so we ended up relying
on the taliban to keep us safe that's
like letting charlie manson babysit your
kids
it reminds me of the portland mayor who
decided to make peace with antifa while
shafting the cops
we chose a regime that stones women to
death for showing too much ankle at the
expense of our troops
so why so many smart people making bad
decisions well maybe they're not that
smart or maybe politics polluted their
decision making driven by a still fresh
loathing of trump or our country itself
having to get out by the end of august
was a political choice a self-induced
deadline with the emphasis on dead
not providing adequate security another
political choice we couldn't have that
many troops there right
that's bad optics they thought well i
got worse optics a target with more
sitting ducks than a decoy factory
remember how under trump it was a new
crisis every day every hour cnn told us
the walls were closing in
from the steele dossier to the tax
returns and every phony scandal in
between those scandals were the good old
days high caloric low nutrition outraged
junk food
compare and contrast to now kabul's the
real deal real horror real scandal a
blind consensus of sheer incompetence
so what do we do well i'm no military
general but then again does that matter
we must take responsibility for our
people over there get them all out and
obliterate those responsible for the
bombings
and when we're done we can decide what
to do with joe and the rest of that
clown car
think about this after committing 20
years to one effort we accepted the very
opposite of that effort quickly and
without looking back
like a husband who tells his wife and
kids that he's going out for cigarettes
only to never return leaving his loved
ones vulnerable and unprotected someone
should pay for that
but in the meantime i don't want to hear
about january 6th climate change mass
mandates or voter suppression or
whatever gassy stupid political theater
you're trying to pedal until you figure
out how to get us out of this mess
but maybe asking them for help to get us
out is as stupid as relying on the
taliban for the same thing
[Applause]
welcome
tonight's guest
he's so white he thinks oatmeal is epic
food fox news contributor tom chalu
he's the second most popular joe on the
show ryder comedian joe devito
he's the third most popular joe on the
show comedian joe mackey
and the first thing she does when she
wakes up is thank the gardener for
mowing around her
fox news contributor cat joe
all right
so uh tom
uh how did you how did you feel after
listening to the biden's speech did it
did you feel confident in his abilities
to lead us well it was similar to most
of his press conferences he was
completely
out of it that image that you showed
it's so the most interesting thing about
that image is really it's not the image
itself it's that he couldn't answer the
question right so joe does things when
he can't answer the question sometimes
he laughs it's always inappropriate
sometimes his laughter sometimes he
buries his head in his hands sometimes
he says come on man but the thing was
the amazing thing if you search this on
google and you look around the
mainstream media the way they wrote
about that image which is i mean we're
not going to forget that image he was
stuck he didn't know what to do
they said things like washington post
said
biden shows frustration with reporter
obviously an emotional moment it wasn't
an emotional vote he couldn't answer the
question and the thing is if you even if
that's your interpretation that biden
was showing frustration with a reporter
that's not a story right the story is he
can't answer the question yeah yeah so
that's not good not good joe
i
my defense which i had there briefly in
the monologue is that it really isn't
joe's fault because it was the democrats
and the media who just wanted he thought
that he was the best chance to win
despite his decline in faculties and his
inability to lead so they put him
forward they said we'll worry about
leading later we'll put him in there so
isn't this more on the democrats and the
media who pushed him there not so much
this befuddled
sad man well he's definitely a befuddled
sad man but before that he was an
obnoxious blowhard for about 40 years
that is true i stand corrected stopping
mine
uh yeah i have as much confidence he's
going to lead us out of this uh he he
couldn't he couldn't lead andrew cuomo
to ladies night that's how out of that
he's he's pathetic and and i see that
the amount of spin they're trying to put
on this they are really losing touch
with reality because if they're trying
to say well we had to get out of
afghanistan eventually okay i think
almost everyone agrees with that nobody
disagrees yeah in hindsight we probably
could have gotten out of there
in 2006 yeah because i really think the
only nation building we should do is the
nation that's located between mexico and
canada yeah we don't need to mess with
these other countries right but it's the
difference between saying you're on a
bus and we need to turn around you apply
the brake you pull over you don't veer
off the road and smash into a brick wall
right and say but i stopped the bus
isn't that what you wanted yes so what
we're seeing it's not a failure of our
troops it's not even i hate to say this
i don't even think i can blame the
taliban they're doing exactly what
they've always done it's the people who
are supposed to be in charge of this
country and
when obama was quoted as saying don't
underestimate joe's ability to f things
up i think we're just seeing the
beginning of that yes to use an old
adage you can't blame the frog for what
the scorpion does to the frog
i don't even know what that means
sounds frank i got that off i got that
off of a cracker jack no joe uh i don't
know uh what your feelings are towards
donald trump good or bad
but
hi
i'm asking you to hypothesize would he
have done this
uh it's a tough question to answer but
it is weird to hear joe biden say i'm
stuck by that may first deadline that
trump negotiated to withdraw
but by my calendar it's late august yes
so
it's also a weird situation to me
because
i got fired from telemarketing for being
too polite
yes
yet it seems like the washington
generals have more success against the
harlem globetrotters than the generals
in washington have success
in anything
but they never seem to lose their job
and and it seems like when
when they
uh they create a disaster and then i i
turn on
uh a lot of mainstream media and it's
the same people that were involved in
creating this disaster that they're like
hey how should we get out of this
disaster there's like there's no
consequences ever yeah and biden was
part of the disaster for eight years and
he pretends like he was always against
this and you can it's not that hard to
find tape of him talking about nation
building don't you just type in google
but joe biden nation building
you can even go back a much more recent
history to where he said that the
taliban wasn't going to take over and
this wouldn't look like saigon yeah yes
wrong on both counts kat so you hosted a
radio program today in which one of your
callers was your husband a veteran who
spent time in afghanistan yes any uh any
wisdom to be shared with us yes uh
wisdom all from him not me but
he's it's been really crazy watching him
watch all of this for the past few days
starting with before the horrible things
that happened yesterday just seeing
troops and taliban like standing next to
each other he said when when he was
there in 2012 taliban were like ghosts
and the way he put it was we never saw
the whites of their eyes till after we
shot them dead right um and going back
to the generals and the in the
leadership he's saying that you know
when he was there was sort of the end of
the time period where it was really a
combat operation
so he was wondering if those troops who
lost their lives had ever even seen
combat before this
um if they were not trained properly he
said there was basically things like
spread out and this and that and support
it's not their fault but
all of this
there should have been time for that
training they just let you know these
guys were sitting ducks all for the sake
of a symbolic
deadline for political points yeah
that's all it was to get it so that joe
had something to say on 9 11 20th
anniversary i love one thing i say
before we go to break i love how
the media is saying you shouldn't be
talking about impeachment because that
cheapens the whole process the media
that had pushed for two impeachments one
based on a phone call
and in this case
anybody talking about impeachment is
talking about it based on a rage over
the death of americans but
talking about it in that vein that just
cheapens impeachment but about that
perfect phone call
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else